il ya un an cette montréalais dont cinq
étudiantes du collège de maisonneuve
reprenait l'avion pour le moyen orient
nous avons eu des nouvelles de certains
de ces étudiants qui sont présentement
en syrie dans le territoire contrôlé par
l'état islamique selon les sources se
rencontrer un des jeunes étudie la
médecine le matin et pratique par la
suite dans un hôpital il s'est marié
avec sa copine qui elle aussi étudierait
la médecine ils étaient partis ensemble
à la mi janvier 2015
nos sources rapportent que le jeune
étudiant ne participent pas aux combats
il ne possède plus son passeport
canadien cependant et serait comme pris
en otage par l'état islamique
on nous a dit il est contrôlé là bas il
ne peut pas parler on ajoute qu'il ne
peut pas sortir du territoire contrôlé
par l'état islamique
le seul espoir c'est de le laisser un
peu loin du front des batailles et de
l'armement
nos sources nous indiquent que les
proches craignent pour le jeune homme si
jamais il revenait au pays ils
risqueraient la prison dès son arrivée
ce qui a fait dire à un de ses proches
qu'il préfère le savoir en syrie en
train d'aider les enfants au canada dans
une prison selon cet avocat spécialisé
en immigration
les jeunes qui ont rejoint le groupe
armé état islamique pourrait faire face
à la justice
à leur retour au canada il pourrait
vraisemblablement y avoir des
accusations ne peuvent pas être s'en
sortir et plaider que oui on a fait du
match fut médias qu'on n'avait rien à
voir mais hélas
en principe c'est la participation à
l'organisation
quelle que soit la fonction même si on
est franchement humanitaire on a
participé à l'organisation criminelle
la grc affirme que chaque cas est
différent et refusent de nous donner
toute information sur l'enquêté experts
disent qu'il faut d'abord rassembler des
preuves
une tâche complexe pour les policiers le
principal défi des corps policiers
c'est de recueillir de la preuve en zone
de guerre donc les policiers ne peuvent
pour se déplacer et aller en territoire
contrôlé par l'état islamique pour
écrire de la preuve comme on
recueillerait de la preuve si le crime
avait été commis ici
au canada toujours selon nos sources
plusieurs jeunes communiquent
régulièrement avec leurs proches
d'ailleurs un autre jeune couple parti à
la mi-janvier vivrait sur le territoire
contrôlé par l'état islamique
il serait mariée est sur le point d'être
parents nous savions déjà que six mois
après son départ les parents d'un des
jeunes ont reçu un appel d'une
mystérieuse agence leur annonçant que
leur fils était mort en martyr dans la
ville de tikrit est en irak
son père nous confiait récemment je suis
dépassée c'est pas facile je cherche
toujours les voyous les lâches qui ont
fait ça et qui sont ici à montréal
l'homme a toujours confiance que la
gendarmerie royale du canada arrête les
responsables plusieurs proches des
jeunes gardent contact avec la grc
il se demande pourquoi les policiers ne
sont pas intervenus pendant que les
jeunes et en turquie en attendant de
passer en syrie
il souhaite que les vidéos de propagande
terroriste soit dénoncé parce que selon
leur expérience ils ne représentent
nullement la réalité de l'état islamique
ici karen bass et radio canada montréal